good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the Tuesday April 23rd
19 session in our series on
entrepreneurship and Asian high-tech
industries I'm very happy that this week
we can feature a startup that is
cross-border between Taiwan and the
United States in the kind of IOT space
for medical care or patient care
applications we have we're very honored
to have dr. Jason Wong who is the
director of the Center for policy
outcomes and prevention and also
associate professor of pediatrics at
Stanford University and he chairs the
mobile health and other new technologies
group at the Stanford center for
population health sciences he got his BS
from MIT his doctorate from the Harvard
Medical School and a PhD in policy
analysis from Rand after he completed
his pediatric residency training he at
University of California San Francisco
he worked in great at Greater China for
McKinsey and company and in 2000 he was
recruited to serve as the project
manager for the Task Force on reforming
Taiwan's national health insurance
system now all of those are great in
addition he's a past recipient of the
NIH National Institutes of Health
director's new innovator award for
creating mobile apps for health but
specific to our seminar series today he
is a co-founder and currently advisor to
this medical IOT company named Medicus
tech and I won't say any more I'd like
to turn the microphone over to dr. Leung
Jason thanks so much for coming to being
with us for that thank you very much
thank you
Oh can everybody hear me yes okay great
so if I could just quickly take a poll
how many of you are engineering students
ok this was quite a few and how many of
you are in health care medical students
or students from health policy okay
wonderful
and how many of you are professionals
oh okay so we have a very nice mix here
and so actually my my office it's not
too far from here it took me about five
minutes to walk over here today and it's
a real pleasure thank you Richard for
inviting me because I don't usually give
this talk at Stanford because I used
actually give health policy talks and
and it's great that we have a sort of an
interdisciplinary group here so I have
financial disclosure which is I serve as
a co-founder and advisor for America's
tech so today I'm gonna walk you through
some of the topics the first one is
increasing role of Technology in
healthcare and then what it's like to
straddle a start-up between Taiwan and
the United States across the Pacific and
also tell you a little bit about what
we're working now America's tech and
also the challenges that I see in
healthcare IOT space so this is probably
the most famous drawing in of medicine
and it's called the doctor so you know
in the 1800's there isn't really much
that we could do for a patient
penicillin wasn't invented until the
1900s and you can see this mom is just
really exhausted over there and Dan is
really worried over there and the doctor
is thinking thinking about the patient
what to do with the patient and this
child is very sick
so we move from what's happening in the
role of a physician as sort of a
counselor as sort of almost like a
priest type of you know role to a highly
medicalised situation in the ICU and the
ICU was started in 1950s by 1970s
of the places have implemented it and
and so what I want to point out too
about this picture is that you could
hardly see the patient's face anymore
and there's all these tubes and you know
I bet if you go to your office or your
room there's a lot of wiring to that you
know a lot of plugs that you need to
plug in it and and a lot of the times
you know just to plug in to the right
place is difficult and and so it
requires a lot of sort of good design if
you were otherwise you're gonna plug the
oxygen tank into you know some explosive
situations and so um and now moving into
today so we're already here actually a
lot of the hospitals are now sort of
wireless and either with you know Wi-Fi
or Bluetooth or different sort of
communication protocols and they're
trying to wire patients monitoring
devices different devices in the
hospital and sometimes even across the
hospital into the nursing home
facilities assisted living and even into
the homes and so what that means is that
in the future and you know there are
some places that's already doing it
today is that the information is gonna
get transferred across hospital walls
under certain protocol and certain
encryption is going to be necessary and
and there's HIPPA laws that guard
against sort of the misuse of this type
of data but it's going to happen and
what it also means is that if you're not
careful somebody could have a virus in
there and could steal all your data and
that's what happened to target went
through the ventilation system went into
their financial system and so you know
all these things could happen it's gonna
be super convenient but as we move into
sort of the the next generation of
caring for the patient patients are
going to move
from the hospital including emergency
room ICU into the outpatient setting
into the home setting
sometimes in community clinics and
long-term care facilities and so they're
gonna be in different states so they
will move from here that may be their
first and then go to the long-term
facility maybe put a hospital and
bounced between the different care
institutions so what do you do with the
data and what do you do with integrating
the data and make sure you can make
sense of it and then help the patient to
improve on his or her health another
thing is that usually in in academic
medical centers we do a lot of treatment
surgeries you know procedures but really
the entire full cycle of care starts
from prevention early diagnosis and even
after treatment there's post treatment
and survival if the patient survived
then you obviously wanted to return to
function so if they go to school you
want them to go back to school if they
have a job you want to go back to work
and if they are not gonna survive you
want to make sure they have good
palliation strategy so that they could
figure out what's important to them and
set goals and so all this requires sort
of us thinking about the physical care
environment and the virtual care
environment and that that's really what
we're talking about today that the use
of Internet of Things is going to be
Internet of Things everywhere it's gonna
be data and data is gonna allow one to
create algorithms and sometimes using
machine learning it could even get
automated and so so what's what's that
going to look like and so you know a lot
of viewer I think Bill Gates was the
first person to wire his home into
everything connected but this is not you
know you could just go buy a nest or or
any sort of cameras in Costco and you
can hook it up and and basically there's
a lot of data that's going to be
available and so
however there are some issues with
integrating consumer technology into
electronic health records and the the
typical records that doctors use right
so one is of the data clinically valid
right then validity is extremely
important why because we use the data to
treat patients so they say if somebody's
Google's is really high you need to
adjust for insulin if somebody's blood
pressure is really high you make them
take blood pressure medications so you
have the story like their nose who
basically was not ready and people get
really sort of in danger because they're
not ready and these information could be
used to make medical decisions so we
need to make sure that the data is valid
right so now you have Apple watch and
that could you take arrhythmias and a
lot of things that people wear that
would tell you if your rhythm strip is
normal if you're having arrhythmias or
or you know some claim to measure blood
pressures accurately but a lot of this
is subject to validation so I just
wanted to point out that anytime you you
create or invent a medical device you
need to validate it the second thing is
is the data reliable so if you take it
multiple times is that gonna fall within
a certain range and of reliability and
then there's just so much you just got
two hands so I mean good like wear a
watch on each side or like you could you
know put stickers everywhere I mean
there's just some so much real estate
you have in your body and as far as I
know wearables are for healthy people
that wants to track how many steps but
sick people they want to extirpate
themselves I've never seen anybody who
has a tube in them
to keep them in there they don't want
any stickers in their body either okay
so I mean what in a state of confusion
or or or in a state of illness you
become a very different person and I
think that that's something that I think
technologists need to recognize when you
approach a patient and they could start
with your family member that's aging and
so they're very different they don't
want to wear at all these things a lot
of elderly don't want to get tracked
they don't want to know what what they
don't want you to know where they are
okay and then there's this issue of open
versus closed systems so if you have an
open system right like used to be
Windows in Intel but now it's Android
and everybody else right and and
Microsoft is coming back and but then
that's an open system but then if you
have a closest unlike Apple then you
need to if you create something you
where do you fit in like do you fit in
to open system or do you fit into a
closed system and if you're starting a
business
how will you compete so so that's that
and you know it's all also it's very
difficult to not create a new standard
right you want to create a new Android
or a new iOS system or you know you know
a new Microsoft system so and then the
last issue is there's a lot of missing
data so a lot of these fit bits
apparently went into people's washing
machines when when people are tracking
the Fitbit data and there's a lot of
missing data so these devices you need
to charge them sometimes you forget to
take them out and so if you are tracking
people heart rate or respiration or
anything meaningful clinically
meaningful and you're missing like 12
hours of the 24 hours how how can you
trust the data to make clinical
decisions and so that's another issue
that I think hasn't been completely
address and
sure that in the future we'll get there
but it's just not there yet
so the other issue is the digital data
right so you go from these individual
devices and you're gonna integrate into
where where's the data call and there
are a lot of companies that want to be
platform companies but I haven't really
seen one that's really viable because
that means everybody needs to give give
you their data and that's been
problematic so you have these individual
little cloud servers everywhere created
by different companies they don't really
talk to each other and so where's the
data aggregation gonna take place and
also you have these large electronic
health record systems that are sort of
kind of outdated in their technology but
they have dominant market share and so
how do you work with them and how do you
deal with the nine captured data or the
lost data so this I mean this area is
very exciting but there's really a lot
of work to make it happen and I'm pretty
sure it's gonna happen within you know
10 years because it's just moving very
fast the technology is but the
compliance issues the regulatory issues
are moving a lot slower particularly in
healthcare so the data from electronic
health records and the digital health
space and sometimes even telehealth
space if you talk to patients remotely
via video conference are gonna be
available for healthcare settings for
home for individuals and are gonna come
from these places as well the data will
be used now in health care but for
research to track patients outcomes
right so they say that I'm a
geriatrician and I need to probably
wrong three nursing homes in the weekend
each one has a hundred beds there's 300
patients I would never get to go home
but most of the 300 patients are not
sick maybe there are 20 that's sick
that will really require my attention so
I should really spend my time taking
care of these 20 patients and the the
other a you know 280 patients I have
normal data to show that they are normal
and so how do we get how do we more
appropriately use cognition time and
save costs for the healthcare system I
think that's another challenge right and
then pharmaceutical companies obviously
also want to track some of these things
so they want to know if they give you a
chemotherapeutic agent or a drug that
you have side effects from it they want
to track how you're doing but they're
getting clinical trials they tend to be
very very expensive and there's a way to
track patients status at home or even
you know more conveniently that would be
an opportunity so technology is a tool
anytime you have a tool you need to know
when to use it and that's the context
and so here at Stanford in my lab I have
a lab called a habit laboratory it's a
health analytics behavior intervention
and technology habit HEPA laboratory in
our cellar where we basically we trained
clinicians to work with designers and
engineers and that includes programmers
and data analysts so a lot of times
clinicians only know about
pathophysiology and how to treat the
patient but they have no idea how to
design something so when they designed
something that doesn't look too good
nobody wants to use it and so the
designers usually are not training data
analysis so they don't know where to put
the data like that the interface and
where the data go and the data analyst
even though they could come up with
really good algorithms and and and and
and information for the clinicians they
need to work with the Keynesians
to figure out how to do that so we
basically integrate all these different
knowledge together and we train people
together here at Stanford so now I'm
going to move to the opportunities that
I saw in Taiwan several years ago so
just a little bit about Taiwan Taiwan
has population of 23 million so it's a
little bit bigger than Florida in terms
of the population Florida has 21 million
its a GDP of about half a trillion
dollars and in the u.s. we about 17
trillion population over 300 million so
it's a very large tip you know
difference in size and population so why
why did I go to Taiwan now I'll show you
why first of all I'm ELISA regionally
from Taiwan and that's probably the
biggest reason I get to visit family ok
and the food is pretty nice all right
and Metro Metro is pretty nicely set up
in Taipei is very clean so I like to
visit right to visit family and I like
to enjoy the culture but if you look at
and this is a slide on Michael Porter so
if you look at tywin's national cluster
export portfolio and this is the share
of exports so each one of these little
bubbles this sizes rustics billing so
you could see that Taiwan is is it's
growing in its shares of information
technology it's doing ok medical device
but it's really grown in this area and
these areas are declining but the idea
is that there's a lot of industry
aggregation so when I do a start-up in
Taiwan within a one hour drive I could
visit all the suppliers and vendors and
basically build a prototype in two weeks
so if I have a clinical idea that I want
to make it happen two weeks I just go
around powering different
gidget's and let's just say hey can I
follow that can about that and if it
works I'll buy it from you and so people
that has power all sorts of stuff and
and we just put it together like a toy
like a piece of Lego so really is the
idea that matters that you could and the
ability to put it together taiwan also
makes about half of all the
semiconductors in the world the Taiwan
Semiconductor cut manufacturing company
TSMC and a large proportion of pcs and
and and forms and notebooks all made by
Taiwanese companies the other thing is
that if you look at the Pens and so each
one of these bubbles 3000 pens so and
it's this is sort of growth or pens so
Taiwan is doing pretty well
South Korea is really doing very well in
sort of growing but the numbers in
Taiwan this is 1 million pens per 1
million population is really high up
here and so there are a lot of things
being created but then you look at the
wage right it's nine dollars an hour so
if I spend a thousand I spent fifteen
hundred dollars a month I could hire a
really great engineer from National
Taiwan University fifteen hundred
dollars a month and these are like top
engineers they they you know they score
the top level on national exam and so
and and they they're used to sort of
working with companies like tsmc and the
ones that work with TSM C then they
become more expensive but we could get
them in a relatively good sort of in
terms of you know salaries I think
there's a lot of talent that's over
there now there are even though they are
strengths so they have very strong
clusters availability of scientists and
engineers math and science education is
excellent University Research and
collaboration is excellent
it'd become even better in the last few
years there's intense local competition
good solid IP protection and
infrastructure is all very good there's
some weakness as well so legal framework
could be improved and I think the
government has been trying to actively
trying to improve it in the last few
years for startups and for VCS there's a
large brain drain I live over here I
don't live over there but I mean there's
a lot of people coming over to the
United States and our model has been
brain circulation not brain drain so we
will send our engineers over there we'll
send the Taiwanese engineers over here
to to look at how we do things and our
engineers over there to look at the
manufacturing process because they need
to know how things are made and so the
cost of doing business and the tech
system three four years ago there was a
lot of bureaucracy but I think the
government realized that that's a major
issue for businesses to locate in Taiwan
and so they've done a lot of text
reforms around that environmental
regulations still need some work
low prevalence of in warranty rec
investment and in terms of management I
think the management talent needs
further development compared to the
United States compared to Silicon Valley
so one is that it's a gateway to China
it's strategically located in
asia-pacific region and it's mostly
small to medium sized businesses and so
there's there's quite a bit of
opportunities
she's got world-class technology and
intellectual property protection and
logistics I think it's the best part
which is you could pretty much source a
lot of the equipment's in a very short
distance and people do a good job
reliably
them and so if you are thinking about
doing a startup and you create you do
design thinking here at Stanford and you
create your portal type you might want
to just visit some of those vendors
because it's gonna save you a lot of
time try to you know even put a
prototype together and start a
manufacturing process and so I think
there's quite a bit of advantage of
doing that and right now there are a lot
of companies now that are just visiting
Taiwan and if you're interesting just
visiting you could you could you could
contact these people and they could set
up like these visits for you like a
little tourism except it's for like
logistics for IT startups and so they
will just take you everywhere to source
with the companies and to see if they're
interested in making what you are making
okay so I'm gonna now give you an
example of our own startup it's calm
Erica's taken and I have to confess I am
a reluctant entrepreneur I don't know if
you heard of that if not I just made
that up so about six or seven years ago
my friends from MIT came to me and say
hey you know Jason we we've been at our
jobs for a while and when I early 40s
and like kind of have a midlife crisis
and and and they say you know let's
start a company and I said well you know
I'm actually kind of busy because I have
to see patients I have to teach I have
to do research you know and so why don't
I introduce people to you so I happen to
know some engineers in Taiwan there are
excellent engineers they also want to do
startups and so I kind of match them
together I say you know you go meet with
this person at this time and see if you
like each other so then the next thing I
know they flew to my office here at
Stanford and say you know Jason we want
to start a company but we don't know
each other
you need to be in it and then that was
like why was the matchmaker
you know like matchmakers are not
supposed to be part of the marriage
but anyway I I to facilitate this I I
agreed to it and and so I was one of the
four cofounders of the company and you
know even before we started we have to
think about sort of what problems were
solving because the issue with engineers
and it's not criticism of engineering
students but a lot of engineers want to
create something and then try to sell it
try to fit try they're like oh you could
use it for this too but really I think
what really ought to happen and this is
you know being taught here at Stanford
all the time is you need to know what
problem you're solving first like and
how are you gonna know that right and so
you know we have to take people through
a design thinking process but but we
started with what which problems were
solving and what's our competitive
advantage if we want to do that compared
to existing solutions or other solutions
out there and we have to prove that our
solution works and that we have a good
market strategy and and people willing
to invest in us and so so the company
was started in 2012 by whole bunch of
doctors and engineers and with the
vision of integrating technology for
safer care environment okay so my sort
of expertise even though I do most work
in children on quality of healthcare
okay and so you know I want to make sure
the care environment is safe and we want
to develop effective products to provide
useful information for healthcare
settings so you know if you see like a
problem that happens to one person I
don't think you want to jump on that
okay you want to see a problem that
happens to a whole bunch of people so
creates a theme like oh wow this
happened again well how do we how do we
solve that and then from there you see
you get your opportunity and you get
some ID
that how you want to do that and start
to think about prototypes of how you
might do that so we came into this issue
that we knew was happening and this is
again now my expertise this is in
opposites right spectrum of the elderly
population but we realized that the
biggest opportunity right now is the
baby boomers right everybody's reaching
65 everybody somehow wants to live at
home but really cannot afford it
independent living is an issue and if
you go to a nursing home it's gonna be a
hundred fifty thousand dollars a year or
you know I mean it's gonna be very
expensive so how do you how do you solve
this problem and when people get old
your muscles are not as sort of you know
your reflexes they're nice good the
muscles are weaker and they fall and it
just turns out there's a million people
fall in the hospital every year do you
know how many beds in the United States
for hospitals Q care hospitals about
milling that means every bed is gonna
have one for every year okay and 60 to
70 percent our best side Falls we also
noticed so this is for the people who
can move around right people can move
around they could fall people who cannot
move around they're gonna develop
pressure ulcers have you ever said on
the airplane for a long time and six
hours and you realize your wallet is in
your butt and you're like oh this is
very painful and that's a pressure ulcer
okay that's a pressure point so
unrelieved pressure point will lead to a
pressure ulcer which in the elderly it
could look like a big hole in your back
like erosion like a little volcano okay
and what happens is that infection
starts to brew and then people go into
sepsis and they could die so you don't
want that and so you want to relieve the
prep the pressure points before it
becomes a pressure ulcer so we
recognized to that
two point five million patients affected
each year and sixty to seven percent are
the choir in the hospital so we began to
think about a solution to address these
two major issues and and also what we
recognized was that these are considered
preventable conditions by Center for
Medicare Medicaid you know what that
means is that insurance companies will
not pay for them anymore so CMS will be
like oh sorry you should have prevented
this fall we're not paying for
additional CT scans hospitalizations
surgeries is all on you the hospital
okay
so that that's pretty bad right if you
have a patient fallen that they fall
quite often in a 200-page hospital every
day there's one fall two hundred pet
hospital every day there's one fall and
if you ever been in a hospital and you
heard a fall you'll never forget it it's
like school and concrete like well now
nowadays we use more carpeting but but
it's pretty scary so basically the
hospitals are on the hook because if a
patient fall is a preventable condition
if they fall too often you know what
happens they shut down the hospital Jay
Cole was shut down your hospital so
dangerous hospital shut down okay and
same thing with the pressure ulcers okay
and so that this is about thirty four
billion dollars a red cost to treat
false average cost of four with injuries
of fourteen thousand and I think this is
now an underestimate because the data is
it almost it's these five years old so
it's much more now and same thing you
know pressure ulcers pressure injuries
they they renamed it to pressure
injuries that suggests that it's an
injury that's caused by somebody that's
like a trigger for a lawsuit you injure
me okay so it went from pressure ulcers
to pressure injuries okay
so this is what a lot of hospitals have
right now that a little strip right and
if the patient gets off in it basically
this strip documents false because you
could never run like Superman unless you
have a cape to actually save the patient
at the bedside right I mean so the New
York Times says is any hospital or
nursing home so well staff that someone
can materialize within seconds for this
the answer is no okay now for most
hospitals if you visited a nursing home
Breeze in a hospital recently to give
their bed rails right so the policy is
to get the bed rails up so the patients
won't just fall right it turns out the
bed rails for sort of unconscious
patients or people with confused
patients they could strangle under the
bed rails but you still have to get them
up I mean its policies and procedures
okay so there's no time to react with
the old system and this is when we're
trying to solve this problem I just want
to check on the time zone five okay okay
all right so here's where Stan first
methodology and Design Thinking ideal is
all around here we started to train
engineers to think this way so empathize
on the situation that we ask them to
observe to listen to people to see what
they're doing to ask them what they're
thinking basically use all your senses
then to defy a problem that you believe
could help the patient okay and then to
ID ID a and some possible solutions to
create a prototype and to test it okay
so this is what we do with our engineers
okay so first we create a little
prototype here and we created a little
like a little human being a type of
prototypes and we we go around nursing
homes we we see how they take care of
the patient how they roll the patient
for those that can move how they help
the patient up to go to the bathroom
when they get up how do they get alerted
when the patient needs to go go to the
bathroom and we talk to a whole bunch of
nurses and basically we just kind of
have fun it's like your fourth grade
crafts project okay except everybody
loves it I mean because you get to play
with toys right then we start to create
like mock-ups you know how are you how
are you what do you what's it gonna be
like like if you sleeping next to the
patient or you're in the room after all
you the nurse in the hospital what do
you do right so we start to like film
people like create like a little film
like how will you solve this problem and
then we start to actually do mock-ups in
the hospital um where the equipment's
gonna be because you know hospitals they
have a lot of different equipments so
they don't they have real estate
problems just like humans okay
they don't want you to unplug the other
thing and plug yours in that's not good
don't try to do that in the hospital
I know you need I phone charges and
everything but try not to kill a patient
oh so so basically we we have our
engineers they get to work and they
started to create the prototypes I tell
you this is two weeks this what I'm
showing you here from this prototyping
is two weeks but the Design Thinking
part took significantly longer just to
understand the problem that took months
just to understand how to solve this
type of problem okay but the actual
prototype in the sourcing of all the
digital materials over there is two
weeks so so we created the system with
that with the control box next to the
patient's bedside that could talk I
could say please do not get off the bed
the nurse will be right with you in
different languages so you could be in
Spanish Mandarin Taiwanese
your mother's voice your wife's voice
actually one of the engineers his wife
said please do not get off the bed that
kind of worked
but then the the we have a sensor pad
the sensor pad has a matrix depends on
where the pressure points are at the
lights up and then the the sends the
message to either a dashboard the
nursing station or an Apple or Android
device okay so this is where it's placed
in the hospital so you got a nurse in
station some of the nursing stations are
too crowded we don't have the real
estate to put the monitor so we could
directly send to the nurses mobile
device control boxes here and in the
area of pressure ulcers we also give
them a pad so they could see how they
rotate the patient so what happens is
that if you do you know how people get
get repositioned in the hospital
for people who cannot turn like stroke
patients patients with stroke so they
have this protocol every two hours or
every hour they turn the patient to the
left then you turn the patient of right
then you turn the patient to the left
and then you need to go and document it
right so somebody came in to the patient
to the left
it's almost like people clean the
bathroom they they right like when they
come and clean the bathroom but it's
always dirty okay same thing okay
you turn the patient to the left next
time you come to patients already on the
left what I do now a father the protocol
Commission's already on the left so I
turn the pages to the right then to the
left right this happens all the time
confusion confusion with the protocol
okay
confusion superb so what what we're able
to do with an algorithm that we develop
and test it over 20,000 patients now
okay is we actually know based on the
way they move if they are sleeping or if
they woken up we know that from the data
we also know if they've set up because
the putt looks different on this sensor
right we also know if it's a kid we also
know if they put their hands on it okay
now we also we also know
if they are now moving to the side of
the bed and we know if that got out
there okay we also know how long they
got out of the bed
so there's suppose that my father who's
you know miles from me I put one of
these and he leaves for the bathroom and
he doesn't come back in 20 minutes I
will get alerted okay but the ideal
prevent him forced to understand when
they get up starting to set up intention
to leak bet and capture them here before
they leave the pen and then for people
who are doing remote monitoring we also
want to know if they left the bed do
they come back some time now this is the
pressure ulcers slide so if the patient
this is this patients be monitored for
pressure also these that these are the
patient - willful false same system we
developed just two algorithms one for
the false for people who can move one
for the pressure ulcer for people
canaveral okay
these are pressure points that have been
there for a while so if a really a
relief pressure point what's gonna
happen it's gonna get darker and darker
and then we could look into a 24-hour
record continuous record to know who
reposition the patient did they do it we
could also send alert to the nurse every
two hours you need to reposition your
patient or you didn't do it well you
know why cause the pressure is you're
not and still not relieved I'm still
seeing this little thing here you need
to relieve that pressure so you know how
to pay nurse turn sometimes they have a
little they make a little towel roll put
in under or they have a pillow okay how
do they know that they've no data how do
they know that they don't so we're
providing them with the tool to
accurately reposition the patient so the
patient does not have any pressure
points okay
and the next generation we could do it
automatically you don't need a person
okay we already done that so so the idea
now is to have cost savings for both the
health care system for the family to
decrease the silat cost so right now if
people have full risk so the nurses go
every shift and they have a survey and
if you score a certain point on a survey
you are a full risk and so what they do
is they put you under like a observation
like a sitter so a sitter just kind of
sits there and the sitter falls asleep
who could be a sitter who could be like
continuously eye open during the night
I don't know anybody like that okay so
you don't need a sitter
you need a runner you need somebody 18
years old just to run around the
hospital saving patients come forward
you do not need a sitter a sitter is
very expensive is like to at least $250
for 12 hour shift okay so basically
you're reducing the need for sitter
reduce the need that it's more targeted
notification right so now you know you
can't alert it and you have we give
people like alerts you you you have 45
to 60 seconds to get there to save the
patient so they sir I you really need a
runner okay and and and so and we we
help the hospital because every time
they get one of these Falls or pressure
ulcers they have to pay for the cause
and they get sued and this bad
reputation for the hospital is terrible
you get out of it like IRS can't it's
your hospital because they want to know
what happened to the patient why did the
patient fall so there's a total audit by
the Health Department okay and then most
importantly we're gonna save lives
why because after somebody Falls their
life expectancy just shortened fifty
percent of people who died within the
year
because they're immobilized so so
particularly elderly I'm talking about
the elderly right so fall is really like
the starting point for something really
terrible to that person so if you could
prevent a fall they could have good
quality of life so it's it's great so
we've not now done this and when I say
we it's really my team because I'm here
at Stanford oh but the methodology is
it's the same you know you just got to
figure it out this is the old slide but
now we have over 20,000 patient days of
data we have zero falls during a u.s.
Hospital trial over one year period
nobody fell on our class zero zero okay
and we did have some Falls early on
women will develop in the system and
this is compared to the average of 3 to
12 volts per per per thousand patient
days okay and so again if you it's five
fours per thousand patient days at 200
per hospital average one for a day okay
so we published the paper this is based
on a trial and Lahey Medical Center in
Boston and and nobody fell we also did a
trial at Kaiser so Alan is important for
for clinical ilt right because you need
to show it works and nobody fell at
Kaiser either and the way we told her
it's the kind of an investment right you
invest $1.00 in the technology you will
save for four to five dollars because
they could calculate that they know how
much they pay for Falls last year every
hospital knows that when you write that
check it's not settle sometimes the
whole quarter of profits gets wiped out
by one check in a hospital so they know
and we have the numbers too so we
because of the the effort in design
thinking in creating the right type of
solutions we are Tim wonder 2017
innovation price there's only one winner
out of that
and vendors at that Inn as 20,000 people
event and so I was given for the most
innovative new product service at energy
at the world's largest annual met take
event we also got the innovation prize
from Taiwan is the former premier so
that's our story it's ongoing now we got
to figure out a sell this thing how to
price it have a scale and I think that's
you know that's struggle for every
startup and we just recently hired a new
CEO 25-year veteran in the health IT
industry and he's I think he's gonna do
the job the way we think about it this
in the beginning you have the engineers
and maybe the doctors and you do the
clinical trials and then you need to
it's like a relay I mean this thing
takes so long and people have different
skill sets so you know we then did a
national search for somebody who could
do the job to take it to the next level
to scale it up and and that's it's been
our strategy I don't know if it works
for everybody some some funders they're
super talented and they learn along the
way and I know what I'm good at and what
I'm not good at I'm not good at you know
running around different hospitals and
trying to sell this thing okay so when
we think about design thinking we often
forget about systems thinking okay so
systems when you try to introduce a new
product to a hospital they are competing
incentives
they're people making money out of this
you know most most hospitals before the
penalty came they don't really care
about false because the more people
other people fall the more money they
make right because if it's free for
service
most hospitals just see the numbers up
and up because they're not doing their
job and but they still get paid there
are regulatory frameworks that needs to
happen
so before there's the i.t i.t system is
just computers going something now
and they usually Bioman right they say
you have a blood pressure cuff and it
goes to pile me make sure I had no
radiation make sure it doesn't interfere
with your cell phone or that right but
now you hooked up the equipment into the
IT system it could get hacked can you
imagine if all the equipment's in the
hospital are now in the IT system who's
keeping track of them are there patches
for attacks for different viruses I mean
this is this is like a issue so every IT
system in every hospital is trying to
figure this out and I don't think
anybody has a good solution yet but
people are super conservative because I
you know if it's under my clock that I
did this innovation come in and
something bad happens man I'm gonna get
fired all right so that's that's a
different issue and I believe this is
totally a solvable problem a solvable
problem we is the same way that we need
to solve for all the computer viruses
that have ever come along it's the same
way that we solve all the human viruses
that ever come at all right every time
there's a new virus HIV or think you
will figure out a combination therapy
things get figured out the type of
cancer a new type of infection you just
need to figure out and I have trust in
our engineering friends to do that
procurement big issue that under capex
or is that under you know disposables
and and things like that market
readiness are they ready
it's bigger hospitals more mature
hospitals already or at the smaller
hospitals where I don't know media
backlash right there's always all these
attacks that's happening cultural norms
hospitals entire different culture
because somebody died a nice everyday
people died there so there's a different
culture people intrinsically more
conservative so
as one deploys this kind of innovative
framework you need to think about design
and prototyping as I mentioned user
experience you just protect your patents
you need to think about your supply
chain how to source your materials if
you want to make a lot of them you do
clinical trials you need to understand
the regulatory all the systems you need
to integrate you need to be supported by
policy so if I didn't have that
preventable condition thing that
hospitals ended up eating the cost I
don't think it's going to drive it
because why would people care well
people fall that's what most executives
would say uh yeah you know if you're not
careful you're gonna fall but right so
if you don't have that policy said no a
patient for you you pay for it and then
hospital starts a really let's think
about how to solve that problem
right deployment Salesforce marketing
customer service I mean if you're a
startup the United States is very large
and you need to provide technical
support so I keep on going back to the
supply chain and I said look it's not
enough to be 90 percent reliable it
needs to be like 99.999% reliable
because I can't send person out there
when it breaks I could just replace it
right and it's very differently in
Taiwan because everything's so close Oh
things break they just send like a
takeover I just think the Metro sits in
to take over and salaries relatively
inexpensive so it's like a totally
different model that we're operating
here between the two two systems and
then when you start sharing and stuff
that's when the liability comes that's
when you're in trouble that's when
people started want to sue you
but figured if you're doing well so
really like you really you really need
to have a team that really understand
the complexity of selling in the
healthcare space and also there are
different considerations for
international market either in the UK in
the United States in Japan you know
we're trying to get into your pen but
they're so different and so we need
slow development make sure we understand
the right players before we could do
anything now fundraising is a challenge
for any startup right particularly
health care if you think about you're
gonna develop like a software and it's
gonna like work in six months and then
you're gonna start scaling it and you
just need might buy more servers and
whatever health care the moment you
finish completely develop your product
even the clinical trials you need to do
right
the moment you start selling it takes 18
months to qualify through hospitals and
their system
so most startup would just die it's just
that it can't wait just you just die
okay so so and so the valley of death is
particularly deep like you know in my
view working with Taiwan this part was
actually very tolerable like you know
working prototype was very fast engine
and polite all very fast but even
production was very fast right but then
once you're trying to have distribution
contract that's when it becomes kind of
hard because then all these contracts
you actually need to deliver and provide
technical support so then you need more
money and then we look at the money I
mean you need like over 20 30 million to
start with and probably a lot more if
you want to do this so our estimate is
you need at least you know 50 to 100
million to scale but this is a big
market I mean like I said you know 200
bed hospital every day there's gonna be
one person falling and people can't
afford that kind of fall rates and and
so it's a big enough market that's so
far we've been supported and so when we
look at this and so you have this lean
startup idea and everybody probably read
the book but I'm gonna tell you for
healthcare doesn't really work it's too
slow so you need you need almost you
need a different way of supporting your
team and
and you know I don't know which smart
people's gonna figure this out and we've
been sort of figuring out along the way
and getting extremely lucky but but it's
not that fast and you know you need to
assess the impact and using clinical
trials but this is probably easier than
pharmaceuticals Pharmaceuticals is crazy
like you take the drug one person dies
and then you're like off the market ten
people die off the market and and so
this is not as bad as pharmaceutical but
somewhere in between and then and then
you could always fill it as the spread
in the scale up if you're not careful
about that barrier that wall that people
put up in the system's level so even
before you think about how you going to
develop the product how are you gonna
sell it you have to already think about
systems issues and integrate that with
design thinking and so so I encourage
you know people here particularly our
students to work with each other
engineering students
healthcare students you know even
business students you have to have a
business model right up in the front
how you gonna price this are gonna sell
this before you develop anything like if
you develop an equipment that leads to
nowhere and doesn't connect to anybody
and the data is not useful and it has
nowhere to go it's not gonna be
successful so you have to think this
through before you spend a lot of effort
trying to do that but in the future
there's no doubt that what we call ilt
is gonna get integrated into the care
environment it's gonna allow sort of
consumer relations management patients
are now all have mobile apps they're
gonna become citizen scientists
particularly with their own data you're
gonna have patient generated data and
you have to integrate it and make sense
out of it and so that this could be a
tool for patient engagement so the
traditional walls of hospitals and
clinics are gonna be broken and when
machine learning and AI are mature
enough we're gonna back to where we
started all the data hopefully you'll be
passively collected to us in
secure way analyzed and just like a
whisper into our ears and you could go
talk to your patient and then the doctor
will be back to holding the hands of the
patient spending the time nursing the
patient not the computer most of my
residents now spend most of the time
nursing the computer probably you know I
bought the patient and nurse the
computer it's not the way to do it the
way that the way is to use the tool in a
smart way and understand the limitations
that the to not there's one bit of
warning that I want to say there's a
hype about AI and I think it depends on
the quality of the data
if the data is crap your training and
crap so your algorithm is going to be
crappy okay if your data is biased and
it's only collects from people of a
certain social demographic group and you
think that's the right algorithm and you
apply it to another group it's not going
to be accurate so I just wanted to warn
that there's really a need for
cross-disciplinary work here now the
doctors the clinicians the nurses people
who understand the care flow needs to be
in the design with engineers that
designers the data scientists like that
graph so that we as Stanford this is
where a great training institution
particularly for this type of thing in
Silicon Valley will be able to create
something that's actually useful and not
another piece of junk okay try not to
create another piece of junk out there
and so with that I will take any
question thank you thank you
[Applause]
you